en 1894 alfred dreyfus fraîchement
diplômé de l'école polytechnique et
stagiaires à l'état major des armées est
accusé de trahison
on l'accuse d'avoir envoyé un rapport
aux allemands ou des secrets de la
défense française sont révélés trois
jours avant noël un verdict est livré
alfred dreyfus est condamné à
l'unanimité des sept juges pour
intelligence avec une puissance
étrangère
cependant l affaire dreyfus dauphin en
fait là que commencer pendant les douze
ans qui suivent la france se divise
entre les dreyfusards qui défend de
l'innocence de dreyfus et les
antidreyfusards convaincu de sa
culpabilité
les tensions sont alors certainement
exacerbé par le fait qu'elle ferait de
dreyfus est alors le seul officier juif
ayant récemment fréquenté l'état major
et que l'antisémitisme est alors
courants dans la société française
pressé par l'envié de résoudre
rapidement la faire par le biais
antisémites et par le fait que daf us
est un coupable idéal
la prostitution va vite monter un
dossier bancal plein de raisonnement
motivés et normand victorieux le
lieutenant-colonel marie georges picard
reconnu pour son antisémitisme fait
alors partie des antidreyfusards
convaincu cependant les années qui
suivent hier contrairement à tous ses
collègues picard prêter attention à
d'étranges irrégularités dans le dossier
contre dreyfus ce qui le fit changer
petit à petit aviez il découvrit en
particulier d'autres lettres venant d'un
autre officier dont l'écriture collait
parfaitement avec les messages aux
supposément envoyés par des fusent après
avoir mené une enquête secrète picard
partager à ses conclusions dreyfusarde
avec ses collègues ses collègues qui le
décrivait auparavant avec des
qualificatifs comme aimable et
sympathique intelligence supérieure avec
une éducation parfaite et une culture
très étendu ses collègues changèrent
boat allemand d'avis aux aussi mais pas
au sujet de dreyfus désormais picard
était devenu leur ennemi du chef d'état
major général dit alors la chose
suivante à propos de picard j'estime
qu'il peut y avoir des inconvénients
grave à lui laisser la direction d'un
service aussi important et qui exige un
jugement plus sain plus kahn est plus
pondérée picard est alors muté puis
accusé d'avoir fabriqué des éléments à
charge contre l'autre officier puis
enfin emprisonné pendant plus d'un an il
faudra attendre encore sept longues
années pour que le procès de dreyfus
soit révisée et pour que l'innocence de
dreyfus et de pika soit reconnu
picard et l
parfait son antisémitisme et même
détestable néanmoins son attitude
vis-à-vis de la sphère dreyfus est en
fait d'autant plus remarquable qu'il fût
antisémites en fait picard avaient
toutes les initiatives imaginables pour
condamner dreyfus et ne jamais
questionner son anti dreyfusards 10 mhz
après tout le simple fait de douter de
l'innocence de dreyfus était un sérieux
danger pour sa propre sécurité comme il
le confie d'ailleurs à son ami et à son
avocat comme ses collègues picard aurait
pu accueillir toutes les remarques des
dreyfusards avec mépris et mauvaise foi
ce qui me stupéfait dans cette histoire
c'est que malgré tout picard ne céda pas
à la facilité
il préféra explorer les détails de la
fère et chercher le fin mot de
l'histoire
plutôt que de se contenter de la
conclusion qui l'arrangeait mme picard
ne se demanda pas s'il pouvait croire en
la culpabilité de dreyfus comme on peut
se demander si l'on peut croire en nos
convictions malgré des incohérences
potentiel avec des données empiriques
picard voulait avant tout comprendre
voilà qui contraste complètement avec
ses collègues dont l'attitude était
celle de soldats pour utiliser le terme
de la génialissime jules haag élèves en
effet le langage habituellement utilisé
pour décrire leur approche est
clairement fortement inspiré du langage
militaire
les collègues de picard voulaient
défendre leur position attaqué les
positions adverses détruire les
arguments opposés ne pas céder de
terrain et avant tout gagner le procès
par opposition picard avait adopté
l'attitude d'un explorateur
ils voulaient creuser l'histoire
questionner ses prémices et explorer les
hypothèses alternatives picard était
avant tout motivée par l'éclaircissement
des mystères la clarification de la
sphère dans son livre de scarlett
mindset que j'ai donc traduit par le mot
d'explorateurs julia ghallef raconte que
après avoir essayé d'enseignés l'esprit
critique pendant de longues années elle
s'est rendu compte que son enseignement
des probabilités et des biais cognitif
était probablement avant tout un échec
certes ceux qui suivaient son
enseignement retenait des principes
comme la mise à jour bayésienne ou le
biais les coûts irrécupérable cependant
selon elles ces personnes échoué à
appliquer ces principes à eux mêmes
surtout lorsqu'il fallait réfléchir à
des sujets émotionnellement chargée en
fait en pratique c'est souvent pire que
ça ces outils sont souvent utilisés pour
dénigrer les avis contraire parfois même
de façon violente et pas pour
s'autocritiquer et s'auto améliorée
selon jules haag et l'efs le goulot
d'étranglement de l'enseignement de
l'esprit critique
c'est beaucoup plus l'attitude qu'on
promeut et encourage cherche-t-on de
nouveaux outils pour défendre ses
positions et vaincre devant les débats
nous sommes-nous motivé par la quête
d'une compréhension plus juste et plus
complète du monde sommes-nous en mode
soldats nous sommes en mode explorateurs
l'un des chapitres que j'ai trouvé les
plus intéressants dans le livre de jules
haag lfc celui qui porte sur la notion
de confusion car il me semble
particulièrement bien incarner la
différence entre le mode solo et le mode
explorateurs après tout un soldat
déteste la confusion en fait pour
défendre sa position au mieux il a tout
intérêt à se convaincre que sa position
est juste et à rejeter tout ce qui
pourrait questionner une potentielle
confusion sur ce fait ainsi lorsque les
collègues de picard ont reçu un rapport
mitigé de gaubert qui doutaient de la
similarité entre l'écriture de dreyfus
est celle de la lettre révélant les
secrets de la france ses collègues ne
semble même pas avoir pris note de la
confusion légitime que ce rapport aurait
pu engendrer
ils ont demandé la vie d'une autre
personne moins expertes et l'ont poussé
à conclure que les écritures était
identique dans son livre juin galette
donne de nombreux exemples le fait
d'accepter ou non la confusion a conduit
de nombreux intellectuels vers un
changement de paradigme ou non par
exemple dans star trek
spock suppose constamment que les
humains sont rationnels et quand il émet
des prédictions erronée plutôt que
d'être confus d'avoir émis une
prédiction erronée il se contente
d'affirmer qu'il n'est pas responsable
de l'imprévisibilité des humains
globalement spock passe un très sale
quart d'heure dans le livre de julia nef
où il est régulièrement pris comme
l'exemple d'un individu a absolument par
explorateurs et d'ailleurs absolument
pas rationnel non plus parmi d'autres
exemples jus la galette donne celui de
l'homéopathie dans les années 1850 dont
le succès médical était remarquable
cependant les scientifiques de l'époque
n'ont pas pris le temps d'être confus
par ce succès et selon julia ghallef
c'est bien dommage en effet s'il avait
pris le temps d'être confus il aurait
probablement enquêter et aurait sans
doute découvert l'efficacité de
l'hygiène contre le choléra abondamment
promue par les médecins homéopathes bien
sûr en pratique enquêter et ça prend du
temps et le nombre de données étrange
est énorme ne s'agit donc pas de se
mettre à explorer tout ce qui n'est pas
clair pour nous cependant plutôt que de
balayer ces données d'un revers de la
main et de les jeter à la poubelle
selon jules haag et l'efs l'explorateur
lui pronote de la confusion de sorte que
lorsqu'un nombre suffisant de confusion
semble pointer vers la même direction
l'explorateur se met à enquêter sur ces
confusions
j'imagine que vous vous dites peut-être
c'est bien joli cette histoire
d'explorateurs mais en pratique c'est
insupportablement coûteux de constats
m'en vouloir mieux comprendre le monde
en fait ça semble même souvent
indésirables et bien justement le coeur
du livre de julia khelef porte davantage
sur les bonnes raisons d'adopter le mode
explorateurs que sur les méthodes à
appliquer pour devenir explorateur
c'est même un livre incroyablement
enthousiasmant sur les bienfaits du mode
explorateurs par opposition aux effets
indésirables du mode soldats notamment
sur le long terme y compris dans des
domaines comme le militantisme le
bien-être mental ou la réussite
professionnelle
prenons l'exemple des start up beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs et d'investisseurs à
succès affirme que pour réussir sa start
up il faut sotomo jt et se convaincre
que la start up qu'on est en train de
monter va être un succès pour ensuite
mieux bouchité et convaincre les autres
cofondateur et investisseur au moins dit
on souvent qu'il faut faire preuve de
beaucoup de confiance en soi
or le mode explorateurs prom lui le
doute et l'incertitude
alors je précise quand même que le
raisonnement avec l'incertitude peut
très bien conduire à des quasi certitude
et à des plans très bien établi une
probabilité de 99 999 %
c'est une probabilité très proche de 1
et quand les données sont univoques
ça peut s'obtenir avec assez peu de
données et du coup la balance
risque/bénéfice peut ensuite être
univoque comme par exemple dans le cas
des vaccins mais surtout jura ghallef
insiste sur la distinction entre la
confiance sociale et la confiance est
systémique la confiance sociale c'est
celle qu'on projette à travers notre ton
notre présence et notre aisance sociale
et ça en effet surtout pour trouver des
investisseurs
ça semble très important et très utile
mais ce n'est pas la même chose que la
confiance est systémique la confiance
épistémique elle c'est celle qui a à
voir avec le degré de confiance sur nos
prédictions futur ou sur notre
description de l'état actuel des choses
pour illustrer cette différence juin à
kiev pour l'exemple de deux des
entrepreneurs les plus en réussite de
l'histoire à savoir dfp dos et il ose me
sq
lorsque ces personnes actuellement les
plus riches du monde cherchait des
investisseurs
il ne disait pas qu amazon était ce là
étaient des succès garanti bien au
contraire mais aussi par ya 70% sur
l'échec d'amazones tandis que musk
expliquera en 2014
je ne pensais pas vraiment que tesla
aurait du succès je pensais que nous
allions probablement échouer
et alors on pourrait se dire pourquoi
ces entrepreneurs dont il est investi
des fortunes et leur carrière dans des
projets qui selon eux allaient
probablement échouer
j'espère que grâce aux 45 épisodes
précédents cette question n'a plus de
mystère pour vous en effet ce qui compte
dans ses prises de décision
ce n'est pas si la décision sera
probablement jugé être une bonne
décision
a posteriori par des observateurs enclin
aux biais du résultat la bonne question
à se poser c'est celle de l'analyse
risque/bénéfice ou 10 en termes
bayésiens c'est celle de l'analyse
contrat factuel et dans les cas de bge
hausse et musk en particulier ceux qui
les a convaincus de se lancer c'est que
la probabilité d'un succès monumental
n'était pas si faible et les
conséquences d'un échec n'était pas si
dramatique
en fait malgré l'incertitude énorme leur
pari leur semblait nettement gagnant
leur balance risque/bénéfice leur
semblait nettement penché vers l'action
c'est cela qui leur a permis d'avoir une
grande confiance sociale
malgré un énorme tout épistémique
mais s'il ya une chose à retenir
ruag élèves plus encore que le succès
prédictif du mode explorateurs et son
énorme utilité dans la prise de décision
s'il ya une chose à retenir c'est
peut-être avant tout le bonheur que le
mode explorateurs peut procurer en fait
pour aller au bout des choses juin
ghallef nous invite à nous auto affirmé
explorateurs je suis un explorateur ou
du moins j aspire à devenir un
explorateur quel que soit le sujet
abordé
qu'il s'agisse de maths de physique ou
de sociologie qu'il s'agisse de
politique de morale ou de religion
j'aimerais surtout parvenir à être avant
tout explorateurs disons aussi pédagogue
quand il s'agit de converser sur ces
sujets j'aspire à questionner mes
croyances collectives et confusion est
constamment corriger mes modèles de
pensée
quand j'entends des bizarreries a priori
stupide mais venant de sources crédibles
qui affirme par exemple que le sol
accélère vers le haut que la somme des
antilles est égal à - 1 12e ou qu'il
existe des ensembles ni fini ni infini
j'ai envie d'avoir le réflexe de
m'écrier in show sting et pas c'est
stupide mais surtout je cherche avant
tout à trouver du bonheur dans cet
exercice
quand j'ai émis une prédiction et rené
plutôt que d'ignorer mon erreur ou de la
justifier avec un argument de mauvaise
foi et plutôt que de ressentir à devoir
moral admettre mon erreur comme si
c'était une photographe dans laquelle je
devrais avoir honte
j'aspire davantage à me demander comment
j'en suis venu à émettre cette
prédiction à creuser les raison de
l'imprécision de cette prédiction
si celle ci existe certaines erreurs de
production étant parfaitement justifiée
et à me demander comment améliorer mes
prédictions futur en mettant typiquement
un jour mon modèle interne du monde
aspirent avant tout à trouver du bonheur
dans l'erreur et dans l'exploration de
son origine et entre nous je trouve ce
changement d'attitude vis-à-vis de
l'erreur incroyablement reposant
stimulateur et enthousiasmant même si je
ne suis qu'un exemple anecdotique
mon expérience personnelle montre
clairement la possibilité d'être un
explorateur heureux mieux encore
l'exemple de julia ghallef montre que le
mode explorateurs peut largement
engendré à la fois du bonheur et du
succès si vous en doutiez vivement
peut-être qu'il s'agit là au moins 2 de
données qui devraient conduire à une
petite confusion dans votre modèle du
monde